jolie ville du bas mènent laval s'est
installé dans un site pittoresque sur
les bords de la mayenne épinière de
trésors historiques laval offre à la
vision du touriste toute la grandeur de
son histoire du pont-neuf l'oeil
embrasse la vallée de la mayenne en
amont le viaduc et en aval le vieux
château imposant de reliques du 12e
siècle est à ses pieds
l'humble vieux pont d'un siècle sont
quête des murs de cinq mètres
d'épaisseur surmonté par une
extraordinaire charpente le donjon du
vieux-château points cumulant de la
farouche façade dressé au dessus de la
manière du moyen-age la renaissance le
logis sur coup en surprend par cette
délicate ornementations
en bas traversant une charmante cité
cool la mayenne la plus sage et la plus
aimable des rivières sur ces morts les
vieux très vieux bateau lavoir curiosité
présence d'un temps révolu
mais laval présente aussi un autre
visage celui-là bien moderne
l'harmonisation c'est fait avec le don
du passé et les exigences du 20e siècle
la ville connaît une expansion
importante usine industries nouvelles
s'y sont implantés les quartiers neufs
et sortent de terre quand j'ai créé une
population toujours plus dense
mais laval est aussi un gros marché de
grains de volailles et de bétail aussi
chaque samedi de nombreuses ménagères
viennent faire emplette au grand marché
qui se tient au pied de la cathédrale
vieille ville bleue pic à l'ombre du
château des hommes ont laissé là leur
nom et leurs souvenirs
ambroise paré le père de la chirurgie
qui souleva les doctes colère en son
temps par la hardiesse de ses méthodes
dans le traitement des plaies il met
également au point les premiers
instruments de trépanation à l'image de
l'endroit où depuis cet homme de bien
les vieilles maisons offrent aux
touristes toute la noblesse de leur
passé
et
ville surprenante chaque lui et pour le
flâneur un nouveau sujet des merveilleux
remarquablement conservé la porte de
buzz serait celle a flanqué de deux
tours rondes agrémenté de machinerie
mais à quelques pas établie en queyras
le très joli jardin de la perrine où se
côtoient pour le plaisir des yeux grands
arbres guillaume châtaignier et cèdre du
liban
oh oui
et bien ce lot marqué ici par les
rigueurs du liber alternent avec les
somptueux gazon et les parterres de
fleurs
tout de cette fraîcheur et beauté nous
amène tout naturellement à parler d'
henri rousseau dit le douanier autre
gloire de laval
ancêtre des peintres naïfs il est entré
dans la légende par ses peintures
empreinte de vérité et de candeur gentil
rousseau disait de lui guillaume
apollinaire oui gentil rousseau
gentil et charmante ville que la main